your character stays true I mean he's
also you know he's it's a dangerous
character he's so stoic and in his own
head you know his mind working like a
computer all the time and he's so kind
of
emotionally unavailable compared to most
most human beings I mean my big fear was
that I would not be able to create an
interesting character for the screen
that people would be like bored out of
their mind watching the show because
this guy's not charismatic or
interesting enough because there's on
physically externally there's not a lot
going on until there's just the until
there's an explosion of action that we
kind of look forward to but really he's
a rather still character e externally